hello everyone welcome to the biggest
ideas in the universe i'm your host sean
carroll
and today we're doing a q a video for
idea number 20 which was
entropy and information unsurprisingly
to no one's astonishment
this uh topic generates a lot of lots of
questions lots of good questions
uh i know that you know i've talked
about this stuff for a very long time
and
uh the questions are good because it's a
very rich area a very important area
and it can be a little bit confusing
it's both conceptually confusing and
also the vocabulary
borrows words that have slightly
different meanings and their technical
terminology would imply so
you need to think about it a little bit
it's all figureoutable but and also of
course i should mention
not all the questions here have been
answered right i mean we are actually
trying to improve our understanding
in some of these areas so there are
research level questions that we run
against but anyway
all this is to say let's not mess around
too much let's just dive
right in except i do want to mention one
more thing i mentioned it already in the
video but i want to do one more plug
for my book from eternity to here the
quest for the ultimate theory of time
because this book really dives into
a lot of the questions that were being
asked in the q a and elsewhere
uh i talk in this book at the end about
cosmology and the big bang and
multiverses and inflation
but most of the book is devoted to the
topic of entropy and its relationship to
the arrow of time why there is an arrow
of time
what it has to do with entropy okay so
buy the book that'll answer a lot of
questions
let's just dive in and the first
question i want to talk about is exactly
this relationship between entropy
and the arrow time
the fact of the past is different from
the future
versus time itself we might say
so here's what happens and i i'm not
exactly sure how to stop it from
happening um
i talk a lot about entropy and the fact
that entropy increases over time
in closed systems like the universe when
i make the claim that that
asymmetry between past and future is
what drives all of the asymmetries
between past and future that we notice
in our everyday lives and therefore
gives us the arrow of time and so people
seem to feel
that they want to therefore identify
entropy with time or the second law of
thermodynamics with
the change of things over time something
like that so
i want to distinguish between these two
things they're extremely different
things
even though they're related to each
other and they kind of sound the same
there is
time which is a coordinate on space time
right
or something that your clocks read right
time is a way to locate yourself we did
a whole biggest ids video
on time and what time is then there is
the arrow of time which is a very very
specific
feature of time in our universe so
no one is saying that entropy is
responsible for time or that the growth
of entropy is responsible
for time or anything like that if you're
ever tempted
to think that something like that is
supposed to be true just think of space
think of the analogy with space in
newtonian mechanics just like
in relativity there's a similarity
between
space and time these are ways of finding
yourself in the universe they are
measures that help you locate yourself
with respect to other stuff if you want
to find yourself
if you want to tell somebody where to
meet you you tell them where you're
going to be in space and when you're
going to be there
in time none of that has anything to do
with entropy or the arrow there is no
arrow of space
out there in the universe but there is
still space right
the existence of space does not require
an arrow of space
as we mentioned there is an arrow of
space here in this room if i take the
pen and i
drop it it will always go down we all
know that's because we're in the
vicinity of the earth and entropy is
like that
so the existence of the earth and its
gravitational field
gives rise to an arrow of space but
space would be fine
even if the earth were not near likewise
the increase of entropy over time
gives rise to an arrow to time but
time would be fine if entropy were not
there
there's a related question you know what
about uh
entropy decreasing subsystems
in the universe
so if i take my
favorite sub sys oops that was pretty
bad subsystems
um my favorite example
is putting a bottle of champagne in the
refrigerator its entropy goes down
okay uh does that mean that it gets
younger that its arrow of time
reverses well no that is not actually
true and
part of me once just give a glib answer
here i mean the question is if you can
locally decrease entropy in some region
does the arrow time reverse the answer
is no
but okay so why is that true and part of
me wants to just say well
look the arrow of time is a more global
phenomenon okay
if you're lowering the entropy in that
bottle of champagne
it's because you're increasing the
entropy somewhere else by itself it
wouldn't happen it's not the spontaneous
flow
of a system from high entropy to low
entropy so it doesn't really count as
the arrow of time
i think that's true as far as it goes
but part of me also wants to admit
that this is a complicated question and
we actually
i don't i don't personally have a fully
worked out answer
to this question um i think it depends
on the circumstances i think that if you
had a
large enough and sufficiently complex
system
that somehow its entropy was set to
decrease in the right way you could get
a reversed arrow of time
but even that it's not exactly the same
as putting in a refrigerator
okay i mean if you have a box of gas
with all of the
molecules bouncing around i could
imagine you know just in thought
experiment land
freezing the box delicately arranging
the momentum of every single molecule so
that they're in a specific
incredibly finely tuned configuration
that will decrease in entropy over time
and then maybe you get a reversed arrow
of time that's the actual
time reversal of the ordinary situation
that's not what you have
in a refrigerator in your refrigerator
there's no pre-arrangement
of the atoms or the molecules in the
champagne bottle
they're just bumping into the walls of
the champagne bottle
and it's in a lower temperature
environment so it gradually decreases to
a lower entropy state
there is a difference between those two
things you are decreasing an entropy
because of fine tuning of your initial
conditions
and decreasing entropy because you're at
in you know contact with some lower
temperature heatbath
i am sure that that difference makes a
difference for understanding the arrow
of time but to tell you the truth i
couldn't
completely work it out so this is one of
the examples i wanted to give of
something that is you know worth
thinking about it might be worked out in
some paper by reichenbach or something
in the 50s i really don't know but it's
a good question but but ultimately
just because i unshuffle a deck of cards
does not mean its arrow time is
decreased
okay it's not a closed system by itself
um
good that's one question another
question is you know i gave you
i think four different definitions of
entropy
and i didn't give you the most basic one
let me give you
uh another definition of entropy what we
might call a thermodynamic entropy
and of course in some sense the other
entropies we talked about are all
thermodynamic in some sense
um but remember i did say that the
concept of entropy was invented before
boltzmann came along to give us the
boltzmann entropy or before
gibbs and boltzmann and others gave us
their formulas for entropy
so clearly we had some definition of
entropy even without all this machinery
of statistical mechanics and course
graining and so forth
and so clausius is the guy who generally
gets
credit for this rudolph clausius and
uh there's a this becomes very
complicated and very ugly because this
is in a world where
we're imagining that you know gases or
fluids or whatever
have things called temperatures and
pressures and entropies
uh and that's it okay they're not
derived from some underlying microscopic
description they're phenomenological
properties
of the thing itself so you don't need to
pick a coarse graining or anything like
that you don't know what the molecules
are made of you can still talk about all
this stuff
but it's hard because you know there's a
lot of different things that can happen
in that messy phenomenological world you
need to be very very careful are you
doing a process at constant
temperature at constant pressure
constant volume remember all any any one
of you in the background in the audience
who have taken
thermodynamics courses you remember all
the difficulties here by the way
all those difficulties that you had if
you did take the thermodynamics course
and keeping straight
all those partial derivatives uh with
respect to different things keeping
other things constant
it all makes sense if you first learn
differential geometry
so all of those different choices of
variables to use on state space
it all makes perfect sense if you just
couch it
in the language of the same kind of
differential geometry you use in general
relativity
okay manifolds and vector fields and all
that stuff
now it never happens that you learn
different differential geometry before
you learn thermodynamics so there's very
few courses taught in that language but
i just want to let you know the
understanding is actually out there
anyway all that is to say here's the
definition of entropy
uh the change in entropy is equal to
the change in heat of a system
divided by the temperature so we're
imagining that we have a
system and it's embedded in the heat
bath
and the bath is at temperature t and so
the system was like the champagne bottle
right it could have a different
temperature overall and so it exchanges
heat
with its surroundings the bath has a
constant temperature
and that change in heat with the
surroundings is gonna
level off to zero right it's gonna
change heat either it's gonna take in
heat if it's colder than the
surroundings or it's gonna expel heat if
it's warmer
and so this could be positive or
negative because it's not a closed
system
but eventually it comes to the same
temperature and the exchange of heat
stops
so there's some finite quantity you can
get by integrating
this change in heat okay so
this is nice and this is uh what we call
a state variable of the thermodynamic
system now there's all of these um
caveats here i'm not going to get into
all of them one of the reasons why i
didn't talk about this is that
a lot of the discussion not all of it
but a lot of it in this language
only makes sense if we think about
equilibrium systems
so we think about systems that we've let
settle down or
ones that we have almost let's settle
down and we move them very very
gradually okay we don't put a huge shock
to the system and let things mix up and
go crazy
that's a harder problem that's
non-equilibrium statistical mechanics
and so you get grown-up physicists who
learned this
when they were undergraduates and they
were taught that the
very idea of entropy only applies to
equilibrium systems
why because they were only told the
definition of it for equilibrium systems
but
clearly the definitions we gave from
boltzmann or gibbs or whoever apply all
the time
they require that you have some kind of
coarse graining so it's a little bit
more subtle so there's a trade-off
involved in the usefulness of these
notions but you can show
i mean this is what boltzmann and
maxwell and other people did that this
definition of entropy from clausius
can be recovered in statistical
mechanics using the different
definitions we gave so
this is yet a fifth definition of
entropy that you might be interested in
speaking of which let's talk a little
bit more about core screening
by corresponding i mean remember we
talked about the
system that has a phase space and you
have micro states which is the exact
configuration of positions and momenta
in the pay space but then you say look
macroscopically
i can't tell the difference between some
of these arrangements so i'm going to
put them in an equivalence class
that i call a macro state and the volume
of that macro stage take its logarithm
that's boltzmann's definition
of entropy and so i'm sure that i said
this in the original video but i forget
exactly how much i said so i'll say it
again and hopefully it will help clear
up some of the questions
um people get bugged by this because
they say well you know that coarse
graining
seems to be subjective it seems like i
made it up
but uh somehow you're telling me that it
explains why
coffee cups always cool down right you
know like that's
that seems like i'm explaining some
empirical phenomenon of the universe
which is absolutely universal and
predictable
on the basis of choices that i
subjectively personally make that
doesn't sound like
something that should be in the laws of
physics so i'm sympathetic to this
critique remember when we talk about
quantum mechanics and the collapse of
the wave function
i was and remain horrified by the idea
that something like the measurement
postulate in copenhagen interpretation
of quantum mechanics
you measure a principle of a system a
property of a system and the wave
function suddenly and unpredictably
changes
that doesn't sound to me like something
that should be in the laws of
fundamental physics if you
have no choice then okay but you better
at least make precise what you mean by
measure okay
so likewise it's a perfectly legitimate
thing to say you better make precise
what you mean by this course screen
so i'm not going to say a lot about this
but let me just reiterate that
even though we use a language like
what i can measure about the system what
i can macroscopically observe
what i actually in fact can measure is
not
arbitrary okay the laws of physics
constrain what i can measure about a
system
so you know people were asking about
like what if i have a bunch of molecules
but some of them are painted green and
some of them are painted yellow and i'm
colorblind so i don't know
so there is something called the entropy
of mixing that uh
that does in fact keep track of whether
or not you have
segregated systems by some property that
doesn't affect their motions
in any way right like two different
kinds of molecules that have the same
weights or velocities
or something like that but you can't
really use it to do work
like you know you can't it's not uh it
doesn't uh carry energy with it but it
does increase
over time so all this is figure outable
what i want to get at more
is the way that we actually do
coarsegrain
in real physics is driven by real
physics
is not driven by our subjective choices
when we look at a system we're looking
at
using photons okay and those photons
come from the boundary and they have you
know certain wavelengths and they're
more importantly they're sensitive to
certain things
in other words the laws of visit
and what they enable us to
straightforwardly observe
determine to a very large extent how we
coarse grain
the universe into macros and this
uh is particularly important because
some people suggested you know do we
always have do we automatically have a
past hypothesis
what i mean by this is the past
hypothesis
is the idea that the early universe
starts with low entropy
[Music]
and given that there are many more ways
to be high entropy and low entropy it
will naturally grow
everything makes sense congratulations
it all fits
um but some people said look if your
definition of entropy depends on the
course grading
you can give me any trajectory of the
system through state space
okay start with some actual microstate
and let it evolve through state space
and after the fact i can coarse grain it
so that entropy looks like it's going up
so in other words if here's all of these
space
gamma okay base base and here i have
some system
that starts here and goes there right
there you go and i'm going to say let me
change colors here
let's say once i know how it actually
evolves i'm now going to coarse grain
like this so here's a macro state
there's a macro state
there's a macro state i'm going to say
ha entropy goes up
but i notice i could equally well
so the argument goes correspond this way
there's a macrostate there's a
microstate there's a macrostate
and now along the same direction entropy
was going up now it's going down
so there's the idea that i can just
after the fact make entropy go up or
down just by choosing my course grading
so this is why i feel the need to insist
you don't get to
choose arbitrary course gradings you can
fiddle around the edges a little bit
okay but there is something real
something objective
something that is fixed by the laws of
physics about how we
actually choose to core screen when we
say that we have some
collection of molecules in a room you
know like you open a bottle of perfume
and the scent
goes out this is a uh example that
boltzmann i think
actually looked at right and you say
well look the entropy is increasing as
the gas fills the room
what are you doing you're corresponding
by the density of gas
in physical space as we talked about a
long time ago
in the video about i think the video
about space
um there's a reason why we coarse grain
things in space
right according to location space we
could bring them in momentum space or in
some complicated non-local
combination of things but then the
emergent loss of physics would look like
a mess you wouldn't get any pretty
straightforward
uh understandable behavior there's a
reason why we coarse grain in the way we
do
and it's with respect to that very
natural
coarse graining that entropy started low
in the past and is increasing toward the
future
another question that is related to this
was look if if
gibbs says the entropy is related to our
knowledge
and our knowledge of the universe
doesn't change over time so that the
gives entropy in a closed system
uh just stays constant then how does
entropy go up
the answer is the it's the boltzmann
entropy that goes up it's not the gibbs
entropy that goes up
if you don't look at the system but the
boltzmann entropy does the boltzmann
entropy
requires this course screening but
nature and the laws of physics give us a
course screening that makes perfect
sense okay
it's not nearly as arbitrary as you
might think
there is something you know with it with
respect to that um
so let me just actually mention again i
forget what i mentioned when i made the
video
um but let me mention one little wrinkle
on that that question of
uh the gibbs entropy remaining constant
in the closed system
so if you have a closed system
closed system
and you have the gibbs entropy so
remember the gibbs entropy at least what
i was calling to give entropy that
don't take too seriously the connection
between labels and actual historical
events the history of this is very very
messy and fascinating
but it is minus the integral of some
probability distribution
times the log that probability is
distribution
over the gamma if you want to call it if
this is gamma the whole face base
there's a tiny element of gamma and p
is the probability associated with that
particular point in face-based gamma
okay so this tells you how much you know
about the system at some probability
distribution
p of gamma and it's going to evolve in
time and if you know the microscopic
laws of physics
this quantity the gibbs entropy remains
constant
d s gives for a closed system
dt equals zero and that's not the second
law of thermodynamics nothing's going up
right okay so this is a
a little tiny bit of a puzzle the real
resolution of the puzzle is easy it's
the boltzmann entropy that goes up
um or if you have a closed system but it
is
in contact if you have a not closed
system if you have a system that is in
contact with the heat bath
then there's a version of the second
ball that uses gibbs entropy but what
about this
question so what if i have a closed
system that well a system that is
usually closed
but there's a window and occasionally i
can open the window and look at the
system
right then you might think well when i
look at it if i look at it in a way it
doesn't disturb it so it's not quantum
mechanical it's classical i just look at
it see where the gas is roughly speaking
and i close the window again
um didn't i learn something about the
configuration
system and therefore you can make a more
sharper sounding paradox you can say
doesn't it seem like the gibbs entropy
only ever goes down
okay and isn't that bad isn't that the
opposite of the arrow of time the
entropy only going down
you have to keep your wits about you
because there's many different
definitions of entropy so that's a
simple
way out of that dilemma but you might
want to know what's really going on here
so i actually wrote a paper
um with some colleagues of mine uh tony
bartolotta
jason pollock stefan leichenhauer which
where we invented will be called the
bayesian second law
of thermodynamics so we talked about
bases theorem in the probability video
um bayes's theorem is a way to update
your probability distributions and
usually we think of that as a set of
credences on
propositions or theories or something
but you can think of it as the
probability distribution on
the configuration space or the phase
space of the set of molecules sure why
not
so you can use bayes's theorem to say if
i have some probability distribution on
phase space
and then i look at it i make a
measurement okay
then i can update my probability
distribution and indeed you can show
that the
gibbs entropy should go down just like
that makes sense your knowledge
increases the entropy goes down
but there are other things that go up is
the point there's a there's what
is happening is from the information
point of view uh there's an exchange of
information right you didn't have that
much information you have more
information now but what we were able to
show it's a very complicated thing i can
go to details but there is something
called the cross
entropy that relates the distribution of
molecules before and after you made the
measurement
and the cross entropy always goes up
over time
so there's a sense in which even though
you're learning more and more about the
system
there's something that irretrievably
loses information
even when you're learning about it so
there's always a version
of the second law that you can't escape
no matter how hard you try
okay let's change gears a little bit
let's uh
expand our horizons i want to start with
you know some of the basic thermodynamic
entropy stuff but then a lot of the
questions
you know wants to stretch beyond the the
parts of
uh the story that we understand very
very well into the parts involving
gravity or cosmology or field theory or
something like that so why not it's the
q a we can do that
uh so let me talk a little bit about
entropy and gravity
and an obvious question is do we
understand
entropy in the context where gravity is
important you know i gave
examples where you have a box of gas and
gravity is not important by which you
mean the gravity the mutual
gravitational force between the
molecules i mean it can be
in a gravitational field sitting on a
table that's a different thing but the
mutual gravity is not important
and there we know exactly what the
formulas are for entropy that's the
conditions those are the situations that
all the people in the 1800s were
actually caring about
whereas in the early universe when we
said yes it looks like a black body but
it's actually
low entropy compared to what it would be
the reasoning was that because then
gravity was really really important
so you're very allowed to ask so what's
the formula you know so how do we
actually calculate
the entropy of a box of gas when the
mutual gravity is
important so there are things we know
and things we don't
so for we do understand it perfectly
we we understand it for newtonian
gravity
i'll explain what i mean by that in a
second so
what i mean is you have a box of gas
uh it might be a big box right
megaparsecs across if you want so here's
some gas
and so the gas you know we use the word
gas in a very
broad sense the gas might be stars or
galaxies for that matter
and uh what is gravity in this case if
you are in the regime where gravity is
just newtonian so there's a force
which is newton's constant mass of one
mass of two over the distance squared
between any two
objects um well it's exactly the same
there's no difference whatsoever
you can you can coarse grain by like
volume or something like that
but the point is that um what the
gravitational force
does is change how there's an interplay
between
space space the space the locations in
space
and momentum space so what happens is uh
things want to come together under the
force of gravity so let me actually
erase well let's just keep the picture
there we draw another picture so let's
imagine we start with
a bunch of particles that are relatively
spread out and watch them evolve under
newtonian gravity
well they will seem to collapse it's
true
but they will also speed up okay so even
though
the spatial configuration
is shrinking that does not necessarily
by itself correspond to decreasing
entropy in a box of gas it would because
you have the box of gas you put all the
gas in the corner you just let it go
the box of gas with no gravity in it
well then it just
expands through the box but the
individual motions of the molecules
retain their average velocity the
average velocity doesn't change
only the spatial extent changes and
therefore the entropy goes up
when you feel the bigger volume here
you're filling a smaller spatial volume
but the reason why is because you're
being attracted to each other under the
force of gravity
so your velocity increases so even
though
the spatial extent that you would see
just by looking at it
seems to go up if you're corresponding
by putting in an equivalence class where
you don't know the velocities
there is more phase space available here
because the velocities have secretly
increased
and then what can happen further is
there's no end to this there's no
limit at which the ball has a certain
size and shape the
mutually attractive collection of
particles reaches some size where
entropy is maximized
it never happens what happens is most of
the particles just come closer and
closer together
and a few of them fly off to infinity
right they can just escape
this literally happens when you make a
galaxy like galaxies are
not exactly in thermal equilibrium for
exactly this reason they can be pretty
close
but they can always shrink you know
clusters of stars or
or anything can always get smaller just
by spitting out other things with
hugely high velocities okay so the
newtonian story is pretty
straightforward it's it's a little bit
different
um than the non-gravitational story but
it's not hard to understand
now one of the reasons why there's no
ending here is because
one of the reasons why i said newtonian
gravity is there's no black holes
in this story right there are no black
holes in newtonian gravity so there's no
point at which everything just collapses
to a black hole and then
evaporates but in general relativity
that would happen
now in general relativity there's
another thing that happens which is that
you have gravitational wave
there are degrees of freedom in general
relativity namely
independent fluctuations of the metric
field of the gravitational field
that in newtonian gravity don't have
newtonian gravity you can talk about the
gravitational field
laplace introduced it the gravitational
potential
but it doesn't propagate by itself it
doesn't have a life of its own once you
tell me what the matter
objects are doing the masses and
energies
you completely determine the
gravitational field
in general relativity that's not true
you can tell me exactly what
the matter objects are doing but you
still haven't yet told me what the
gravitational waves the gravitational
intrinsically gravitational degrees of
freedom are doing
so for those for the gravitational waves
in some regime you can treat them just
like photons right like if you could
imagine just quantizing them
and averaging over the number density in
a region
then the gravitational waves are more or
less just like photons but
that's not always the regime you care
about right when you're near
creating a black hole things become more
complicated
so in gr you have of course you know
what the
entropy is for black holes the entropy
the beckenstein hawking entropy for a
black hole we talked about this in a q a
video
by the way i know some people are asking
questions uh who haven't actually
watched the other q a videos because we
talked about some of these so we talked
about the
glycol entropy quite a bit so it's the
area of the event horizon
divided by four in units of the planck
length so we can just write
l plunk square okay so once you settle
down
to a black hole then you know exactly
what the entropy is and you know in
particular that
the entropy of a big black hole is way
bigger than the entropy of the mass
it was made on okay so we don't have a
full story or set of equations for the
entropy
of a fluctuating gravitational field in
general relativity
but we have a good enough approx set of
approximations that are good in
different circumstances
um the other question that is asked then
is well
that black hole evaporates right does
the entropy go up when it evaporates so
i just told you a story
where you know in newtonian gravity the
entropy is increased by things coming
together
mostly and a few things get spit off to
infinity
um if i say that in general relativity
you know this
story goes now i get a black hole right
it's like a white hole here on the
on the uh tablet but there you go this
is a black hole
okay um now that black hole is going to
begin to radiate
right that's what hawking taught us so
the black hole eventually evaporate away
so which is it is it that with gravity
things want to clump together in a high
entropy state or with gravity things
want to evaporate in a high energy state
because this black hole
eventually evaporates away entirely and
you're left with nothing but a gas of
photons again isn't that where you
started
well the answer it so the answer is it's
complicated we know the answer is it's
just a little bit complicated it's not a
simple
you know concentrated means high energy
or low entropy or vice versa it's a
little bit more subtle than that
so in this original picture over here
where we just had
the gas we were assuming there was some
density of gas
and we didn't worry about what things
were like outside or the rest of the
universe
if the rest of the universe also has
particles in it with the same kind of
density then they will
clump together locally in their same uh
in the same way as this one did they
will form a galaxy
this is what actually happens in the
early universe right you have this
collection of particles
they come together under gravitational
attraction they form galaxies
entropy is increasing during that
process okay
um so but then what happens next and you
usually we stop telling you the story
then because that's the current universe
right now right we formed some galaxies
there's empty space in between we know
what's going on
if we follow the story to the point
where either we care about the stars
that were spit out or we actually form a
black hole and we care about the photons
that are spit out
now we have to wonder about what is
happening with the expansion of the
universe
overall so if somehow
we were living in a non-expanding
universe
then roughly speaking you would get a
constant churning of exactly this
process
things would come together i'm imagining
some very fake universe where you can
make black holes but
the universe is not expanding okay so
maybe it's like the einstein static
universe or something
so what happened is you come together
you make a black hole it evaporates
but then all those photons have energy
and other black holes elsewhere
are also emitting photons and they would
come together to make black holes again
and they would evaporate and there would
be constant churning back and forth but
that doesn't sound right like that
doesn't sound like
the final result like in we're taught in
thermodynamics that things eventually
reach in equilibrium
um what would happen is that the sizes
of the black holes you would make and
the sizes of the empty space around them
would grow
over time like if i have a collec if i
have one black hole with a certain
entropy
that's good that has a lot of entropy
per unit mass but if i have 10 black
holes of the same entropy
i can certainly increase their entropy
by smushing them together to make one
big black hole
okay it's entropically favored to make
big black holes rather than
small ones so what happens is that the
scale of lumpiness in the universe would
just grow and grow and grow
over time so it's churning but it's not
sort of equilibrium churning
that you never reach an equilibrium in
this sort of weird
hybrid static space but creating black
holes
kind of universe you grow structure and
structure on
ever ever larger scales now that doesn't
happen in the real world because the
real world space is expanding right
and we think space is going to expand
forever we think that there is dark
energy that is pushing it apart we don't
know
but that's certainly a plausible
possibility and in that case
the other lumps of matter that were made
by black holes
elsewhere are just going to get further
and further apart from each other
so now it is no longer necessary that
all these photons emitted by black holes
meet other photons and create other
black holes
they can just expand apart from each
other as the universe becomes more and
more dilute
and so the question is is the entropy of
these photons
that you get by the black holes
evaporating is that greater than the
entropy
of the black hole yes it is but it also
takes up a hugely larger amount of space
so if there is enough space for that
set of photons and also gravitons and
neutrinos and so forth if there's
enough space for that gas of particles
into which the black hole radiated
to just keep expanding and diluting
without bumping into other matter
then that will be the end point of the
evolution of this
system uh so in fact there was a theorem
the cosmic no hair theorem
which was um
i think robert wald i think bob wolf
from user chicago first
articulated this uh if you have a vacuum
energy lambda greater than zero
either
the universe recollapses so if
you have vacuum energy greater than zero
but the universe is closed and so it
expands but the vacuum energy never
takes over the density of matter is
always greater then it can just
recollapse
okay or
space empties out
and that final state is called
disinterest
wilhelm de sitter famous general
relativist a friend of einsteins they
worked together
and he showed that the solution with
nothing but vacuum energy is an eternal
expanding
internally expanding space so all the
lumpiness that you might want to have
evaporates away in the far far future of
the universe you see why it's called the
no hair theorem
very similarly like the earth or the sun
or some object
can have all sorts of interesting
features oceans
continents and so forth but once you
make a black hole black holes have no
hair all that's left is the mass the
charge in the spin
likewise a universe can have all sorts
of interesting features galaxies and
supernovae and so forth
but eventually if you let it all uh
expand away
you're left with a featureless descender
space
okay and in fact you might say i always
wondered one of one of my favorite
papers that i've ever written
was just a couple years ago with aidan
chatwin davis former caltech graduate
student you know
this statement that as the universe
expands with positive cosmological
constant
it approaches this universal future
state
right the sitter space
just like there was this relationship
between black holes and thermodynamics
that stephen hawking
used to invent glycol radiation
eventually
this also kind of sounds like
equilibration like the second law of
thermodynamics right
like entropy increases and you
eventually reach to sitter space and i
think that a lot of people
knew for a long time or well let's
no is a very strong statement in these
sort of quantum cosmological
realms but a lot of people were willing
to accept for a long time that there was
a sense in which
dissider space an empty universe was
nothing but a cosmodrome constant
was a maximum entropy state of the
universe
given certain conditions but uh what we
actually showed we proved a theorem
um borrowing technology from rafael
busso and neda engelhardt and others
we were able to show that you could
derive a version of the cosmic no hair
theorem
from the second law of thermodynamics so
in other words rather than what bob wall
did which would say here is
albert einstein's theory of general
relativity he gives me equations
einstein's equations and i
show that i approach this empty decisive
space
this bald universe with nothing in it we
did not actually
assume um einstein's equations or any
other field equations for the
gravitational field
all we assumed is that entropy increases
and you know we secretly of course
smuggled in the dynamics of gravity by
saying we did assume
this there's this uh this is the
beckenstein hawking
formula for the entropy of a black hole
hawking and gary gibbons later
generalized this to the sitter space so
there's also a horizon
into sitter space and it has an entropy
that is guess what it's area divided by
four in plankton
so we assumed this equation and that's
where we derive the fact that there is a
cosmic no-hair theorem
so we really made precise that under
certain circumstances
the expansion and emptying out of the
universe really
not just goes along with but is
the second law of thermodynamics in
action which is very pretty i always
suspected that was true and it was nice
to be able to show it under certain
circumstances
okay okay big uh shift of gears now
um this isn't so much a question there
were questions here but
uh i'm not exactly sure how to phrase
what i want to say as a question so let
me just write down topics
life information
and error correction
so once again you know there's there's
in this field there's a whole bunch of
lore there's a whole bunch of things
people think are true
and probably are true you know they make
sense but that's a little bit different
than having a rigorous quantitative
theory
of what's going on so like i just said
for entropy and the expansion of the
universe it was nice to have a theorem
that actually related the two of them
another thing that we say
is look life can't exist in thermal
equilibrium
that would be boring thermal equilibrium
by definition is whatever
if you listen to my recent podcasts with
stuart bartlett or
or older ones where we talk about the
definition of life
being out of equilibrium is a crucially
crucially
important aspect of the issue so
what does that mean why like how what
are the precise exact
ways in which the process that we call
life relies on the fact that we're out
of equilibrium when entropy is
increasing
okay well one way is that life
is kind of rickety right like life is a
complex
system um it's like a car right it
breaks down
eventually like your body you know your
cells are dividing and your dna
is ripping apart and giving rna
information to make proteins and all
this stuff and
there are errors made along the way and
you know to be honest like
the idea of error correction is
one that i'm increasingly impressed with
as a fundamental feature of the cosmos
you know there's something called
quantum error correction which is very
important for people doing quantum
computing
there's also classical error regression
so the quantum error correction people
were building on
uh the classical theory of area
correction it's harder
to correct quantum errors than classical
errors which is why you need an entirely
different
theory of it um but the very idea of
error correction and its
uh connection with entropy and the
second law is is crucially important
like
you would think again it's just like the
existence of complexity itself right
you you ask the question well how could
there possibly be
spontaneously coming into existent
complex systems
all that ever happens is entropy is but
then you ask the question a little bit
more sophisticated way and you realize
the only reason why
complex systems can ever come into
existence
is because entropy is increasing so
similarly analogously you can say well
why in the world should systems be able
to correct
errors in a world where entropy is
increasing shouldn't errors just become
more more frequent and then you analyze
it and you realize
the only reason why systems can correct
errors is because entropy is increasing
because they live in a
if entropy is increasing one of the
prerequisites for that is that entropy
is not yet maximal
right if it were maximal and it couldn't
be increasing so when you say entropy is
increasing
uh you're smuggling in the statement
that the entropy is not maximum
yet and that lets you correct errors let
me just i'm not going to go the whole
theory of this because i don't know what
the whole theory of this is but let me
give you the basic idea
maybe someone in the audience can figure
out what the whole theory is so by error
correction we mean let's say you have
you know some some
signal or some information maybe it's
literally a dna molecule
maybe it's a protein that is going from
one place to another maybe it is a
you know set of nerve impulses in your
brain that is going from one synapse to
another and let's
symbolically say you have symbol abc
or word abc made out of three symbols
okay
and you want to send it down some
channel just like claude shannon talked
about sending information down channels
and there's an error rate
things can get mixed up and so by
mistake it goes to the channel and it
comes out
a x c where x is some other letter so
there's an error
b changed into some other symbol how do
you know
right like it looks because i wrote it a
b c
uh and that looks very different than a
excess c but you know these could be
anything
so in principle you don't know what it
changed so the principle of classical
error correction again i'm not doing
justice to an entirely
huge complex field here but roughly
speaking
you build in redundancy to the system
right you say
okay instead of just sending the signal
abc
i'm going to send a a b
b b c c c
and the principle that i'm taking
advantage of here is that
errors are rare like if errors happen
all the time then you're doomed okay
well
it's clearly going to be doomed if you
have such a noisy channel that it's
impossible to send information then then
you're do
so what we're imagining here is you're
pretty good
at sending information but occasionally
there will be errors and
you're not sure a priori when they've
happened so but if you send this kind of
redundant thing
then a rare error means that there's a
chance for every one of these letters
that it will randomly be changed so it
might change into
a a a b b
x c c c right
the chances that all three of the b's
are going to flip into x
is that much smaller than the small
chance that even one of them would
so then you can clearly see how to
correct this error
if you know that you're supposed to be
sent a signal
where there's redundancy where there's
three letters of the same
type in a row and you get something like
this where there are not three letters
in the same type in a row then you say
well majority rules i'm going to
correct that error to make it b b
b if i were unlucky enough to have two
of them flipped then you know so much
worse for me
but if i make bigger and bigger words
out of these letters then i can always
guarantee
that my error rate will be small unless
it's 100 right i can always make this
or you know there's some cutoff anyway
so the point is
to do this kind of error correction we
need to increase the entropy of the
universe this is the landauer
uh principle right we need to erase that
error that we made and correct it
into something else so we need to have
the ability
to undo that error by creating entropy
elsewhere in the universe
if we were at maximum entropy we
couldn't do that we wouldn't have the
ability to so
our ability to correct errors like this
which is important in our cells dividing
you know like being damaged dna
suffering along the way it's all
possible only because
we can do things very far from
equilibrium in other words because there
is an arrow of time
again not all the theory has been worked
out there's plenty of room for
improvement here but this is the basic
idea i think it's pretty
powerful as well as pretty okay
now we're going to switch for the final
set of topics i want to switch to
um things that nobody understands these
are these were
the last a couple things we talked about
were things that we have a pretty good
idea what's going on but details are
murky
now we're going to go beyond what anyone
understands okay but we're going to
speculate about the ends of space
and time so um let's talk about
uh the number of degrees of freedom
in space time itself
and obviously we don't know that um
and i'll tell you the connection to
entropy in just a second um
because this would require some
knowledge of either the theory of
everything or at least quantum gravity
or something like that
now we do know so what do we mean by
this okay we talked about
long ago we were talking about quantum
field theory we talked about
quantum fields in a region so this is
space
some region a okay and uh well how many
degrees of freedom are there in the
region
in quantum field theory the answer is
infinity right uh and that's because
there are waves of this wavelength and
waves of this wavelength and
so this wavelength don't use that
wavelength an infinite number of waves
number of modes you can fit inside there
okay
and then you say well okay but let's let
me imagine i put a cut off
i don't let you have waves above
or above a certain energy per mode
but above a certain energy per particle
i should say
but equivalently i don't let you have
waves below a certain wavelength the
planck length or whatever
okay then you say well okay now i have a
finite number of degrees of freedom but
you're wrong you cheated you do not have
a finite degrees number of degrees of
freedom because
each one of these little waves i drew
has a wavelength but it also has an
amplitude
remember if you go back to our quantum
field theory discussion
every one of these modes acts like a
simple harmonic oscillator
in the free field approximation anyway
so
for any one wavelength
the amplitude of the vibrations can be
arbitrarily bid
it corresponds to not the energy per
particle
but how many particles are in that
particular mode
so if they're fermions then they might
only have a finite number but there are
bosons in the universe and bosons you
could pack an
arbitrarily large amount of energy into
any single region of space
in quantum field so even with
an ultraviolet cutoff even with the
shortest wavelength and even with what
you might call an infrared cutoff you
have the size of the region
there is still an infinite number of
modes that you could fit in quantum
field theory i keep saying
in quantum field theory because quantum
field theory is
not necessarily the right answer so
it now let's imagine turning on gravity
right when we say quantum field theory
what we really mean is uh quantum field
theory
in some space-time background either
truly in minkowski space or you just
turned off gravity
or you can do what's called quantum
field theory and curve space time you
have a gently curved
space time and still do quantum field
through there that's where we can make
these statements about quantum field
theory but
you don't let gravity be arbitrarily
strong
however if i just say look i can put an
infinite number of modes in this region
of space
by putting more and more energy into
that region of space
then clearly that's in conflict with the
idea that gravity is not too strong
right if i have an arbitrary amount of
energy in a region
gravity is going to start becoming
really really strong
so beckenstein the same guy who came up
with the
idea that black holes radiate and have
entropy pointed out
that there is a bound i mean the what we
call the begenstein bound
refers to different things in different
people's hands but the way that i like
to think about it
is there are not an infinite number of
things you can do
in this region if you actually have
gravity turned on and let it exist
because most of the infinite number of
things you thought you could do
would be more energy than you can put in
that region before you make a black hole
so there's a finite number of modes that
you can turn on
and excite without making a black hole
or you could make a black hole
but black holes also have a finite
entropy
here's the formula for the entropy right
remember the entropy is the logarithm
of the number of microstates that look
like that
so this finite entropy corresponds to a
finite number of microstates
of the black hole and so whether you and
so you include both quantum field theory
states where gravity is not yet strong
and you include the black hole states
but there's still a finite number
okay so this is the idea and this is
not something that is well understood
okay this is not something and
i told you that this is not something
that we all agree on but
i am on the side of people who think
that in
a region of space there's a finite
number of things that can happen and
what that means is
that quantum mechanically the
dimensionality
of the hilbert space corresponding to
that region
a is finite
in fact i think i know what it is um if
you have
the air i shouldn't have called this
region a but so you have the boundary
of a which we call b boundary that is b
then the entropy associated
with a black hole of that size the
entrop
s a would be the area
associated with the boundary b uh
divided by four
l plus squared and if you have a maximum
entropy
state in quantum mechanics the entropy
is
uh let's get it right the dimensionality
of hilbert's space
is e to the entropy so
i claim that there's factors of two and
things like that that we're not going to
pay close attention to here but the
dimensionality of the hilbert space of
things that can happen
in region a is e to the power
of the area of the boundary in plank
units
so a finite number but a really big
number because the planck scale is small
and microscopic areas are large
okay now um this is
a i think this is a consistent story to
tell and it's consistent for example
with the story we told about
the cosmic no-hair theorem i mean this
there's a finite number of degrees of
freedom
in our universe because we have a
horizon around our universe there's a
fixed
size that we can get to and therefore
only a finite number of things that can
happen and this is also
very compatible with ideas that i love
from
how gravity could emerge how space time
itself could emerge from quantum
mechanics right this is the idea that
charles tau and
spiros mikalakis and other people have
been thinking about how you can just
start with fundamental
finite number of gravitational degrees
of freedom and emerge space time in some
way
however this is utterly incompatible
with quantum field theory right in
quantum field theory
again in a fixed background you have an
infinite number
of degrees of freedom in every region of
space and this
this little song and dance i just told
you seems to imply there's only a finite
number and you might say well
so there's two things here one is the
statement this glib statement i make
the gravity does not seem to be
described by a quantum field theory
this is the evidence for that this is
the best evidence for that i mean
there's more evidence from holography
and black hole information loss and
things like that
but this is a simple straightforward
in-your-face piece of evidence that
quantum field theory is not the right
framework in which to do
gravity um that's an incredibly
dramatic statement to make okay
it's not at all clear that it's true
statement i think that it is true but
you know you could certainly disagree
so one way to disagree someone brought
up this question there was this paper
they quoted by suskin
um and doheran and uh cleveland and they
said you know they
suskin at all point out correctly i
should say eddal and suskin
you always remember the most famous
person on the paper but they point out
that it's not necessarily true
that the dimensionality of hilbert space
is
e to the entropy of and they say
there's this sort of mysterious
statement in the paper where that's only
true
if the temperature is infinite the
temperature is never infinite so why are
you thinking this right
so what they have in mind is imagine um
a energy going vertically
and i just say how many states there are
in the theory right let me just
list the number of states of some theory
as a function of energy and so there's
some states
and all this is the only picture i'm
going to draw this is it okay a bunch of
states
but what this means is and it goes on
infinitely so there are an infinite
number of states in the system so this
you know a simple harmonic oscillator is
an example right there are more and more
as an infinite number of states
and a simple harmonic oscillator but
they have more and more energy
so what they're pointing out is that if
you have a system
at finite energy then sure
you can have in principle infinite
energy states
but there's not that many of them or
there won't be that much support for
them
in the system so the actual number
density of these states might go
something like this
right
if i if i plot it this way i put it
horizontally
so basically at fixed total temperature
or fixed average energy
the chances that i will be in one of
these super duper high energy states is
infinitesimally small so i can just
ignore them so they don't contribute to
the
entropy the the case in which the
dimensionality of hilbert space
equals e to the entropy is when
every state in the system is equally
likely in the statistical mixture
that you're looking at and that would
not be true if you have a thermal system
with arbitrarily high energy but
i don't think this is actually what we
have here i don't think that we have a
system where there are
infinitely high energy states we just
don't have access to them here we have
if you tried to make an infinitely high
energy state you would make a black hole
instead okay so this is why we don't
agree or this is why we haven't yet
settled down
on what to say about these systems but
anyway
i think that uh if quantum field theory
is not the right framework in which to
be doing quantum gravity that's very
important
that has a lot of implications and this
argument is a very simple one for it
there's a related thing that i want to
say
people ask about the expansion of space
and the number of degrees of freedom
dof degrees of freedom okay so people
and this is something that is very
confusing and i was very confused about
it for a long time and again
you know i'm advertising my own papers
but
it's my video series i can advertise
whoever papers i want and i want to
advertise mine
so um again this is something where i
was confused and you know i
struggled for a while and eventually
came to an answer that i liked
um if you think about the expansion of
the universe the expansion of space so
here's space expanding and this is time
then here's what you wonder about um
we typically treat the if we're just
doing quantum field theory
if we really were taking quantum field
theory seriously
then you would say okay there are modes
that you know long wavelength modes and
they evolve to long wavelength modes
they get stretched as the universe
expands
and you might be tempted to say
something like
well i'm going to do an effective field
theory with a cut off
remember we talked about this when we
talk about the renormalization video
like
all that stuff i did you know that we
did together the hard work
in that middle period of the biggest
ideas video series about renormalization
and effective theories there was a
reason why we did all that stuff
it does feedback um we said look you
you put a cut off and you don't pretend
to know what physics is going on
at length scales below that cut off you
only do the infrared physics and you
come up with a consistent theory that
talks about that
so we're we can do that and we're
tempted to do that
in a non-expanding universe that makes
perfect sense
well when the universe is expanding
which it is by the way
um it runs into a difficulty
there's different ways of phrasing the
difficulty here's one way of saying it
um there are modes here at this later
time
that here were smaller than the cutoff
right this is the cutoff whether it's
the planck scale or whatever
if i go backward in time and my modes
that i'm keeping track of
expand or contract along with the
universe then any mode
like the a typical photon in the cosmic
microwave background
has wavelengths of millimeters or
centimeters or something like that okay
like that big
if i shrink it back down to the super
duper early universe
eventually it's going to be below the
plank length or anything right any any
wavelength you pick
so how can i simultaneously
say that my theory only talks about
modes
above a certain wavelength when the
wavelengths are changing as the universe
expands what's going on
are new degrees of freedom being created
out of nothing
and if so why are they in their vacuum
state rather than some other state how
do they know
what state to be it right okay
so nobody knows the answer to this
question nobody knows
for sure we don't have a consensus on
what the right way to think about this
is um i did write a paper with some
friends
too many friends to uh let me see if i
remember all the friends uh ning bao
charles sao and liam mcallister we wrote
a paper called
quantum circuit cosmology
and again it's not exactly the new
uh favored paradigm in the world but i
think it presents an answer to this
and the answer is um if you think about
space time as being constructed from
entanglement between quantum mechanical
degrees of freedom
then the way to think about degrees of
freedom as space-time expands
is not that more degrees of freedom are
coming into existence
it's just that more degrees of freedom
are becoming entangled
with each other so basically we have a
map
or we had sort of a relationship between
the usual story
of space time expanding okay
and we say that you can think about that
quantum mechanically as
there's a big bucket of unentangled
degrees of freedom and i will draw them
as little uh arrows to
menial cubits and i don't draw any lines
between them meaning they're unentangled
and this is just like a separate thing
in fact let me put it over here
let me draw it over here this is like a
resource that we have to draw from
as the universe expands and then we have
actual space-time here
oops what we call space
which is made out of degrees of freedom
again little arrows but they're
entangled with each other
okay the entanglement gives rise to what
we think of as the metric the distance
between them and so forth
and so when space is bigger there are
more degrees of freedom
and they are entangled with each other
in certain ways
okay and what happens is that there
this bucket of degrees of freedom still
exists
but new degrees of freedom became
entangled
they moved from the bucket into the set
of entangled degrees of freedom so there
are now
fewer degrees of freedom in our
unentangled bucket
okay so there's a total number of
degrees of freedom in the
theory but only a tiny fraction of them
start out
creating space time the other degrees of
freedom because they're unentangled in
this
uh just aren't part of space-time and
there's a
this what you and i think of as the
expansion of space
is not more stuff coming into existence
but entangling more and more degrees of
freedom from this bucket
no one knows if this makes any sense if
this is somehow
reflecting the ultimate truth of the
cosmos but this is the kind of idea
we're playing with to make sense of
these very difficult very fundamental
questions i mean one of the reasons why
i like this field is because
this kind of picture i mean it really is
this kind of
we have equations in the paper but this
is the idea like
we didn't you know reach this at the end
of a long calculation the
questions we're faced with here are
sufficiently difficult and fundamental
that we're really thinking about what
the basic question is not working out
details of some rigorous calculation
okay and one final topic
uh on boltzmann brain
and i struggle with this one this
particular question
um because i get it all the time or a
piece it's not really a question it's a
claim
that is clearly in my mind not correct
uh maybe it's not even a claim maybe
it's a uh
potential thing to consider and you know
the idea is look
um i have a big box of get
protons neutrons electrons whatever kind
of gas you want and i like when i say
big i mean really really big
and i just let them randomly fluctuate
around for a long time
and according to the boltzmann brain
story if they are truly random and they
have enough energy and enough time
occasionally they will randomly form a
brain or a person or something like that
okay the large number of atoms have a
really long time to wait
eventually that will happen but you can
calculate how long it will take
uh very very roughly and the answer is
way way way longer
than the age of the universe right now
so a lot of people say look
sure maybe that happens but clearly it's
not the most
likely way for it to happen right it's
way more easy to make a brain if you
start with a low entropy universe and
just let it expand and cool
because then you make stars and galaxies
and you have thermodynamics and
entropy increases and you get natural
selection and evolution in the origin of
life
and you're going to get a brain it's a
very natural thing so
sure maybe if you wait a hugely long
time brains will randomly fluctuate into
existence
but that's not the easiest or best way
to make a brain so why should i care
okay that's i'm trying my best to sort
of uh reconstruct what the argument is
so in other words isn't it easier
to get brains and again when i say brain
i don't necessarily mean literally just
a brain floating out there in space
whatever you want okay it could be a
person it could be a whole planet and a
whole ecosystem whatever
finite system with finite entropy you
want
you can the argument that i gave says
will fluctuate into existence an
infinite number of times and
most of the time it will fluctuate into
existence without the rest of the
universe coming with it
okay so when i say brain if you prefer
to think of person or ecosystem
by all means think of it to make a brain
via evolution let's say by evolution we
mean
darwinian natural selection in an
ecosphere like we have
versus randomly
and you know the short answer is no it
is
really not okay and but but let me
explain why i think this is an easy
mistake to make
um you have to compare
two different things you might want to
calculate and remember
the whole uh video last time on
probability
um randomness and probability one of the
things we talked about very weekly were
conditional probability
so you have different events going on in
the universe and a conditional
probability says
if i fixate on one thing having happened
what is the probability something else
happened along with it that's a
conditional probability
so the difference is if you compare the
probability of a brain
appearing to
the probability of the let's say the
past hypothesis so
let ph
mean past hypothesis
and that means oops
of low entropy low early entropy
so the past hypothesis is just the idea
that the early universe started with
very low entropy and we think that's
true
in our universe but the question is why
do we need it
etc so this probability says
okay let's imagine that we
conditionalize
on the universe being thermodynamically
sensible it started with low entropy
expands it cools you make stars planets
galaxies stuff like that
and i claim that it's not that hard to
make a brain in that situation now
honestly we don't know because we don't
know how easy it is to make life or
whatever
but at least as far as thermodynamics is
concerned in this scenario you're not as
far as we know relying on any
really really really unlikely random
fluctuations okay
it is natural for complex systems like
you and me to evolve
in this kind of situation
conditionalized on the past
so we say this is not small right
this is the argument the argument here
is the probability
of a brain with
no past hypothesis so this is not
the logical not operator equals
very small right now this is not
plus you wait eternally long but at any
one moment
okay if you didn't have a low entropy
passed probably you have no brains lying
around okay you only get them by saying
well we wait a
long time so this argument is saying
look if i have the past hypothesis it's
more likely to get a brain than if i
don't have the past hypothesis isn't
that all i need to know
but the point is that's not the thing
you care about in this particular issue
in this particular argument
what you should care about
by the way i'm setting it up it's
obvious what i'm going to say here is
the probability of the past hypothesis
being true given that you know you're a
brain
not a being not a little uh scottish
baby
we know we exist right we know we're
observers we can think we can look at
the universe we're alive
okay conditionalized on that knowledge
does it follow that the early universe
probably started with low entropy
no it really does not very small
that's the point of the boltzmann brain
argument is that uh
all if all you know is that there's a
brain you cannot
by any stretch conclude there must have
been a low entropy passed and the way to
see that
it's not that hard really so like we
have you know a real world
okay the real world again here's space
here's the earth here you are
on the earth okay and so let's imagine
that we want to get the whole earth
okay but so we have the earth but we
also have the entire rest of the
universe
right so let me draw a little dashed
line around the earth
so we have you know other stars
we have galaxies black holes etc
we have a huge thing right trillion
other galaxies in the universe
all of them by the way very very low
entropy
very very low entropy compared to what
they would be if they were black holes
very very far from equilibrium right and
you want to compare
that to
the fluctuated world
where you have the earth let's say you
fluctuate into the whole earth
and you
but outside it's just thermal
equilibrium
so think back
to the first couple of ideas videos that
we did laplace right
conservation of information you don't
need
historical knowledge in microscopic
physics
to figure out where you came from or
where you're going you need the
current situation of the universe the
whether it's the quantum state or the
positions and velocities of everything
so what i do is i compare the likelihood
of these two situations
right now at this moment i don't need to
compare their historical likelihood
because it's the same
there for every microstate that
corresponds to these two situations
there's an
equal number of past microstates that
did because of conservation of
information
okay so the fact
that the real world has much lower
entropy outside
the unit the part of the universe that
we're conditionalizing on mainly the
earth and our ecosystem
versus the equilibrium plus fluctuation
universe
means that this one is in the ensemble
of
all possible states of the system much
more likely
so conditionalizing on the brain or
conditionalizing the earth existing or
conditionalizing under
under anything doesn't tell us anything
about what happens outside what we're
conditionalizing
okay you can tell me what you want i can
build the rest of the universe
and of all the ways i could build it
most of them have a much higher entropy
than the real universe does right so
that is enough
that argument is enough to guarantee
that uh
most of the ways that i could have to
make the earth and a person
on it uh do not come from a very very
low entropy initial condition in fact
there's
you know you can sort of fine grain that
argument a little bit
um you could put like a mini past
hypothesis to give the people who live
on the earth here in arrow
time for a little while okay but most of
the ways to get this macroscopic
condition
earth and you right now have higher
entropy in the past
right that's that was low schmidt's
reversibility objection it's still
true in the absence of assuming a past
hypothesis
most configurations that evolve into
this go from higher entropy and go down
now that doesn't mean we came from there
that means that lo schmidt's
assumptions were wrong that we should
not treat
all the trajectories into and out of our
current macro state as equally probable
what it means is we should in addition
assume the past hypothesis
that's why what we care about is
figuring out why the early universe
started with low entropy and why saying
that well we're here therefore it must
have been true
isn't sufficient we still need some
extra bit of cosmological information
don't know what that is uh but we're
working on it that's why
you know it's cutting edge science
that's why it's a lot of fun maybe you
know if i make these if i make no
follow-up videos 10 years from now we'll
have all this worked out
won't that be that